it is the reunion of the two national
league championship teams last year the
dodgers winning in seven games coming
back from three games to one down ian
anderson 23 year old right hander four
and two 327 era making his 11th start
dodgers saw him in the nlcs he gave him
two runs on five hits in three innings
of game seven of the nlcs so the count
runs full-on bets
did he go
he did bets is rung up on the appeal
contreras came out of the box
waited for the call and then fires the
ball down to third and mookie betts is
out number one
so that's an e5 on austin riley now
justin turner is coming up the la
dodgers this year have hitting the 34
double plays
there's the ground ball dansby's got it
second 4-1 ozzy the turn there's the
double play
anderson needed that dodgers are out in
the first inning and atlanta goes to
work at home next 12th start of the
season for julio urrias seven and two
seven wins tied with clayton kershaw for
the second most in the national league
just one behind
the st louis cardinals jack flaherty so
here's freddie freeman times have been
tough for the braves first baseman one
for his last 14. one two on the way
clubbed high in the air to deep center
field this one's drifting back this baby
is gonna take a ride a home run out of
freddy freeman and it's one-nothing
braves
stars bring out these guys bring out the
best in guys
freeman had one rbi in his last 45 abs
that ball was absolutely hammered after
seeing and see that smile freddie had
with the panda cody bellinger up
for the dodgers the pitch
strike three and bellinger didn't like
that
[Applause]
[Music]
i think he let the empire know it too
alternate red uniforms
the pitch
and a swing and a miss there is the
change up
smith couldn't resist three dodger
strikeouts in an inning in two thirds
one nothing atlanta here's chris taylor
2-2 on the way strike three got him
swinging
anderson and contreras fired up as he
got him with that change-up he loves
pollock and ureas for the dodgers here
in the third inning
and another change right now they can't
make the adjustment he has struck out
the last four hitters in a row
and five in total
freeman hit a home run back in the first
inning it was beautiful a shot to
straight away center tonight
third strike out of the game for julio
urrias as he gets freeman to chase and
there's one down
second walker is given up one out one on
austin reilly coming up
there goes the runner throw down to
second and it is in time to get it all
these thrown out for the first time this
year
and the braves might actually take a
look at this
he's out
nonsense wow
another new york protecting their own
walk of the inning and the game
as turner moves to first his 28th walk
this is again what is exasperating when
you face the dodgers they do not just go
up there hacking away created bad by
bellinger he's about to see a 10th pitch
and he's seen everything ian's got
there he goes 3-2 on the way that time
they got him swung on and missed and a
change-up claims bellinger had strikeout
number six out of ian anderson and
another zero hung up on the board for
ian
gavin lux will be the batter he struck
out his first time chase to change up
now the 3-2 lined into right field for a
base hit rolls against the wall taylor
rounding third
and he will be held there
for the dodgers now with their first hit
have second and third one man out and aj
pollock coming up anderson set here's
the pitch
ground ball toward third they come to
the plate and hits taylor and he scores
riley's throw hit the back of chris
taylor and it's one to one
first and third and julio will stay in
the game now as he'll bat for himself
with the ball game tied they're going to
bun him here
and he puts it in play
and here comes lox and he scores
a head first slide
works
coming on contact the safety squeeze
works
and the dodgers take a lead it's 2-1 and
that's going to be all for ian anderson
who threw 97 pitches and really handed
labor through the fourth and the fifth
innings
justin turner with the bases loaded
dodgers have taken the lead
big pitch in this
young game
here it comes to turner
outside ball four the dodgers take a
three to one lead
talk about getting free stuff
now here's bellinger there's a 3-1 count
with the bases loaded and two out
dodgers three to one nukem delivers
low and inside ball four the dodgers
lead it four to one marias comes in to
score
the dodgers and will smith want to tack
on contreras gives him the sign he works
the extreme first base sound of the
rubber sends one home and there's a shot
up the middle and a base hit
will smith gets it done pools comes in
to score and the dodgers have added on
five to one
the walks have come back to really hurt
atlanta only the two hits and this one
brings in some more runs
that is a bullet and here is chris
taylor
taylor rips one down the line that's
fair in the corner
one run comes in here comes another
chris taylor knocks in a couple more and
it's 7-1 now 8-1
he clears the bases with a double
so freddie freeman's the sum total of
the braves offense tonight let's see if
atlanta can change that here in the
seventh inning they will
feast their eyes on right-handed pitcher
mitch white
paul strike three fastball at the knees
first down to the seventh so one two
count now to abraham el monte
good work for mitchell white sees three
batters strikes out two of them
and the right-hander from santa clara
gets it done on the bottom of the
seventh
so white's gonna hit for himself here
why not after a good inning let's see
how he swings the bat
and have a seat at least for the moment
three up three down again for santana
two perfect innings
so freeman aboard on the first play
first and third with one out
this ball hit high in the air to deep
right field bets gave up on it for a
moment now back to the wall won't get it
it's off the fence that's going to score
one freddy freeman on his way to third
they're going to send him around throw
to the plate short hops and freeman's in
safely saw the braves making a game of
it in the eighth inning a two-run double
from ozzy albee's he's got a two-hit
knight
and the braves inching back closer that
gives the crowd something to yell about
it's 8-3 braves need a ton of base
runners and riley has a single it's up
to
eddie adrianza who's one for three
popped up
pollock says he has it
and the ball drops
one run is in streaking home is riley
he's gonna be safe
three dodgers can't catch one ball and
the braves get a giant break it's eight
to
[Applause]
five nobody out many many times albert's
cleaned this one up
and that one to the back stop nobody
covering the plate here comes nikki and
he's safe
matsuk had a late break to the plate and
mookie scores standing up 9-5
these braves in the ninth inning keep
finding ways to make it interesting and
they're off to a really good start
back-to-back walks to almonte and
inciarte a reigning mvp of the national
league
in the left-hand batter's box two balls
two strikes freeman
strikes out swinging on a 95 mile an
hour fastball there's two out
razor down to their final out
and the 3-2
he popped him up this should do it
bellinger
makes the catch and the dodgers start
the road trip off with a win 9-5
over the braves